louie good to see you what's up hi conan
uh nice to talk to you now where are you
right now louie
i am in henderson nevada okay i live in
in right out of las vegas okay and are
you alone or are you
are you quarantining with somebody well
i'm there's one other person here
i half of the time i'm me
and the other half i'm this person
and you put you put on the wig i put on
the wig
i put on the schmuck you put a schmack
on
that seems pandemicky so it's very nice
so you can be the character you
are in baskets you just put on a wig and
then you can just hang out with each
other
yeah we talk how are you louie
i don't know
so it's kind of that kind of thing yeah
my mom was notorious for going
mom how are you i guess i'm okay
oh god so you just sit down because it
was going to be a while from then on
yeah it kind of takes the energy out of
the room um out of the universe
just hard to do now was that did you get
vaccinated
you got vaccinated i did i just got my
second
shot right and uh god just
right after i got it maybe an hour i
started
nauseated i was feeling sick i called
the doctor i go can it happen that fast
and then i went oh wait
i did stop and get white castle
that could have been
now are you taking care of yourself
because you you look good
are you taking care of yourself are you
are you being healthy are you living
healthy
you know it's such a relative statement
isn't it when people say that when i'm
you know i started the pandemic at about
378 or 80 pounds
depending on what i was leaning on
and now i'm uh 340.
oh good for you i'm trying to get to 275
so i can get into some of my mom's
actual clothes
i got to tell you louis you're killing
backstage here
there's like four people back here
they're laughing out loud very funny
it's a start
yeah we got to build back so yeah so
that's better
you're gonna build back better you're
you're losing
weight uh and you're i'm on the uh
intermittent
fast you know one minute i'm eating the
next minute i'm not
and i take another minute off i figure
that way i'm only eating 30 minutes
out of a 60 which is half so i'm getting
i'm trying to get down to four to 40 20.
you know i'm not eating for 40 and then
i'm eating for 20.
no it's a wonderful thing the
intermittent fasting intermittent
that's a rough one for a midwesterner
yeah you know i just realized that you
just
you have a better version of my hair
this was this was expensive this was yes
like mine
is i've this whole i i'm able to rent
this out for corn and wheat
[Laughter]
now what's going to happen i i just
thought of something
that i'm concerned about which is you've
spent a career
telling really funny jokes about being
heavy
what do you do you're losing weight
you're going to get down to this goal
weight of 275
are you going to retire those jokes i'm
thinking yes
i'm going to retire my fat jokes um
and then you know i think i'll always be
funny but
you know i can't remember doing my first
jokes and i did
1978. uh i sound 100 years old saying
that but
um my first joke you know i um
i i walked up on stage and i go i can't
stay long i'm in between meals
and it got a big laugh that's the first
joke you try out
yeah and then i said i was uh when i was
born i weighed 60 pounds the doctor had
to bring a crane in to slap my ass
so you you hit on this idea early and
you went with it
yeah i was a breastfed baby my mom went
dry
okay come on all right
they're not appropriate but listen this
is why i'm retiring though
yeah maybe you could have retired these
are one more one more
one more one more little run that i love
do you mind if i do it no
go ahead all right i was in the fat
olympics
i uh that pole vault i drove that sucker
right into the ground
i did a good thing now i straighten out
those uneven parallel bars
this is a very inappropriate which one
this is the one that
cracked up johnny carson broad jump
killed her
i apologize to all you women out there
no no no it's fine you mean it in
in the best way